[Music]
andrea's
father you know how much i've always
wanted to see europe bruce
and dad has business there next week
it's some sort of hush-hush deal he
won't tell me a thing
he can't even say when we'd be coming
back will you at least let me try to
talk you out of it
bruce wait please
oh never mind i'm no good at this
here you'll get the idea
[Music]
what do you say
[Music]
of course i will i never thought this
would happen
i i always felt like like i'd thrown you
a curveball like you never knew what to
do with me because i wasn't in the plan
you are now i'm changing the plan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh oh looks like dad's got company
business type company he doesn't usually
see clients here at least not at this
hour
maybe we should wait till tomorrow
before we give him the good news
maybe good night bruce alfred
yes
[Music]
it's another cave all right
[Music]
could be as big as the house judging
from the number of bats that came out of
it
alfred what's wrong this just arrived
[Music]
left with dad too young
need time forget about me
[Music]
my god
[Music]
you